for the first time in a decade and a
half that song is stuck in my head we
have a new trailer for the tomb raider
movie coming out you know me and my
pledge of my blood oath will not get
excited for a video game movie until
video game movies proved to me I should
get excited for them damn Raiders no
different but I feel there's enough to
talk about in this trailer including but
not limited to I was never on American
Idol why not so in this trailer we know
a lot of what we already knew is like
Lara Croft lost her father she goes to
the place she believes he was and then
Tomb Raider stuff but what we don't know
is it looks like this militia is looking
to do a global genocide right there if I
were her I'd stop and be like are you
sure I mean I'm not saying they don't
want to how funded are they there are
terrorist organizations out there right
now in the real world who would like to
do a global genocide they don't because
they don't have the funding the arms the
manpower the nukes at a point this Jews
like they want to do a global genocide
I'd be like yeah it looks like they're
out here just with the thumbs up their
asses playing checkers they're not gonna
do a global [ __ ] genocide from here
unless there's some sort of Idol or
artifact that they're gonna get which
would allow them to do that which I
imagine when the movies gonna be I
haven't played the new Tomb Raider game
so I don't know sure there are people
out there who play the games like I know
exactly what they're talking about and
that is great that you get that Easter
Egg that scene totally looks like in
charted though isn't that cool again we
were like no it looks like Tomb Raider
to me it looks like in charters but I do
like how Alicia vikander looks perfect
for Lara Croft when she was first cast I
was like she's kind of tiny right she's
small she doesn't look particularly tall
but she's got as [ __ ] she inspires me to
work out Thank You Alicia vikander for
motivating me I feel like the good thing
about Tomb Raider is there aren't
warring tribes it's not like humans
versus orcs that I don't I don't feel
like there's one to eight hours of story
you have to cram into two hours if
Indiana Jones was made and worked you
could do a Tomb Raider movie and have it
work this song really did go well with
the trailer didn't it I know this is a
new thing and trailers now the whole bow
is so seven years ago the last two or
three years the thing to do is to take a
song that people know and to remix it
for the trailer make it somber give it a
beat whatever Destiny's Child song in
this trailer actually really went with
the trailer it should now but a first
kicked on I was like alright then I'm
watching it I'm like alright that's why
I wanted to talk about this trailer for
nothing else if the movie sucks the
trailer was at least good I feel like if
they just keep it in the pocket
looking for clues as to what her father
was doing then she runs into trouble and
inadvertently becomes the hero while
showing all the great adventure miss
that adventure can adventure I think we
might have ourselves a good movie I'm
not holding my breath because it is
after all a video game movie and they
always sucks at Mortal Kombat's great so
don't know the movies gonna be good Lisa
vikander looks like she actually kicks
ass on the roll and the trailer was
indeed solid is that a stand off with a
bow and arrow and a gun I would love to
see her win the stand off with a bow and
arrow against our God to rock dinosaur
hunters so many headshots with that bow
and arrow okay so the new trailer to
Tomb Raider have you seen it what did
you think about it you have hope are you
like nah this is the video game movie
that could be good or you like not burn
meat 78 times shame on man or are you
simply in your living room right now
going whatever you think comment below
let me know and as always if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
[Music]